good afternoon i'm michael douglas
one of the many reasons it was important
for me to be part of this first ever
virtual
u.s vets salute gala is because of my
admiration for all people who have
served
for me it's very simple our veterans
stepped up for all of us
and it's our sacred responsibility to
step up
and support those veterans who are
homeless and hurting
and help them on their way back to
self-sufficiency
my belief is the importance of
supporting our veterans is a core
value in our family passed on to me
by my dad kirk douglas
kirk sometimes wore a military uniform
on screen
in cast a giant shadow in harm's way
seven days in may and the final
countdown
but he also wore a uniform in the united
states navy
he enlisted in 1941 right after pearl
harbor
and served an anti-submarine warfare
aboard uss
pc 1139 in the pacific theater
throughout his life he was committed to
veterans causes
and i know he'd be thrilled to know i'm
supporting
this organization now something else my
dad would get a kick out of
is the fact that his son is here to
introduce
the son of one of his best friends
kirk was very close to gregory peck they
were friends
real friends and they teamed up on a
number of important causes
i'm teaming up at this gala with great
peck's son
a veteran who has dedicated his life to
his fellow veterans
please welcome u.s marine corps veteran
u.s
vets ceo stephen peck